aber meine damen und herren bereitete
leinwänden ist meine nummer ist
öffentlich ja es ist nicht das passiert
was ich wahrscheinlich viele von ihnen
werden von wegen ja jemand schon
gespannt sind die zuschauer mit ihren
handlungen von pro minute er ist etwas
anderes vorgefallen bzw sie nicht
vorgefallen sondern ich habe mir etwas
überlegt und zwar habe ich mir sind
karten bestellt bis er eine sim-karte
und habe die in ein zweites handy von
mir gepasst und ich hab mir gedacht okay
das wäre eigentlich ganz cool um
irgendwie mal zuschauer anzurufen also
heute mal anzurufen zu überraschen
welche videos jetzt therapie peter muß
ich nicht immer unterdrücken und bla bla
bla und dann ist mir aufgefallen
ich könnte auch einfach eine wort gruppe
machen so besonnen paar exklusiv von
reuters hf würde davon hätte ich jetzt
hier an meinem handy wie 6 % gruppen
kreiert lucio 123456 die haben teilweise
wirklich sehr interessante bilder ja das
ist ich bin ich mit einem stofftier und
oder das wild in der luft
zwei gruppenleiter sie gerade auf dem
klo und hatte in seinem profil
aufgenommen ich habe mir auf jeden fall
dabei gedacht meine damen und herren
diese sechs gruppen erstellt und das
sind gruppen in denen nur ich schreiben
kann also nur der admira nachrichten
schreiben gruppen info bearbeiten et
cetera das ist mir im großen und ganzen
habe ich gedacht habe war ich einfach
ich mache eine ortsgruppe
mit ein paar neuen von euch und ich kann
da ab und zum verstaatlichten einsenden
und bilder einsenden wenn ich dir
immobilien oder wenn ich mal live stream
mache privat exklusiv für euch dann
erfahrt ihr das halt da allerdings 256
leute ein bisschen wenig gewesen werden
glaube ich also ich meine ich habe auf
youtube gegenüber 3,1 millionen
abonnenten so ich glaube dabei ein paar
mehr leute in eine box gruppe das finde
ich natürlich auch sehr cool deswegen
habe ich sechs whatsapp gruppen gemacht
also insgesamt 1500 leute von euch haben
die chance in diesem konzept gruppen mit
mir mit dieser prepaid sim kartennummer
von jetzt kommen jetzt stelle ich frage
wie kommt man denn diese gruppe
ich habe unten in der video beschreibung
6 links reingepackt das sind die links
zu der oper 123456 einsätze der
eurogruppe vom sechs unternehmen ihr
könnt einfach wenn ihr mit eurem handy
dort das video anschaut auch einen
dieser links drauf klicken und dann
steht da in die gruppe noch nicht voll
ist dass ihr der gruppe beigetreten sei
das wird kein krasser chat mit tausenden
nachrichten pro tag wie bereits gesagt
ich hab das ganze so eingestellt dass
nur ich dort nachrichten schreiben kann
und nur bilder seinen kanon links posten
kann et cetera pp und das video heute
ist nicht gesponsert auch wenn es
vielleicht so rüberkommen weil ich so
oft trotz absage und irgendwie telekom
prepaid sim karte oder so dass keine kur
oder irgendwie du weißt ich habe nur
dieses handy hier noch herumliegen
gehabt und habe mir dann eine sim karte
stellt für wirklich 10 euro oder so
gedanken könig ein paar wort zu gruppen
machen wo ich euch einfach exklusiven
content bringen kann sagen ich mache
also bilder senden wie gesagt
sprachnachrichten nichts da habe ich
direkt ja heute abend damen und ein
video online also einfach nur eine
spaßige aktionen und natürlich klar das
ganze bringt das mit was im titel steht
meine nummer ist öffentlich also wenn
ihr der gruppe seit weiß ja jeder könnt
ihr auch mal in kontakt leben und dann
seht ihr meine nummer deswegen ist
allerdings das ist alle
benachrichtigungen herausgestellt habe
ich bin den flugmodus mit wlan unterwegs
das heißt man kann mich auch nicht
anrufen das heißt ich hoffe dass ich das
handy nicht sterben wird falls sie
sterben wird
werdet ihr ja sehen dass ich mich in den
gruppen nicht melden wäre allerdings auf
den punkt zu kommen freunde ich will gar
nicht dass dieses video hier so lange
wird ich habe mir einfach gedacht hey
warum eigentlich ein handy gruppe nicht
ein paar sachen schreiben nun mit bilder
wenn ich in dem skateboard auf die
fresse für die geschichten es gibt viele
programme mit denen man sagen kann ja
diese nachricht soll an diese diese
diese diese diese gruppe verschickt
werden
das ganze möchte ich nicht jede gruppe
soll sein eigenes ding sein und ich will
in jeder gruppe meine eigene nachricht
schreiben das heißt ihr werdet zu
sprachnachrichten von mir jetzt nie
irgendwie die gleiche hören sind luxus
wie in yushu 4 oder bilder auf den
bilder werde ich schon ab und zu mal
weiterleiten weil wenn ich nur ein bild
von dem ereignis habe dann schenkt die
zeit an euch alle allerdings soll jede
gruppe will die von eigenes ding sein
ich habe aber jeder wie gesagt einfach
sein eigenes dummes ein bild gemacht ich
habe auch hier so tolle der nordpol ist
im norden
hallo ich bin locker und ich stinke
jeder gruppe soll sein eigenes team für
sich seine party und
ich würde ich das sofort platz listen
werden wo ich meine nachrichten rauscher
und euch sagen ein neues videos online
sondern wirklich so cool ich kann euch
wissen was erzählen und ja bitte
versteht aber dass ich nicht machen kann
dass jeder von euch schreibt weil das
250 sondergruppe alter oder handy würde
sterben werden direkt an und hier findet
ihr jetzt auf jeden fall in der
beschreibung 6 links da könnt ihr
einfach mal vorbeischauen draufklicken
in der woche drauf habe dann seid in der
ortsgruppe mit mir und einigen anderen
leuten ihr könnt allerdings wirklich
nicht schreiben weil das wären zu viele
nachrichten und dann wird mein handy hat
sterben ich hoffe dass das ganze
funktionieren wenn ich auf ihre freiheit
dieser aktion
das ist wirklich einfach nur für euch
als eben ist ein echtes scotland habt ja
ich schreibe immer gerne die kommentare
was ihr davon haltet in zukunft wenn die
sechs wochen voll sein sollten und wenn
ich natürlich auch noch irgendwann 90%
gruppen eröffnen allerdings soll das
ganz weg bis zum exklusiv bleiben
ja ich hoffe dass sich alle benötigten
ausgestellt habe und nicht tausendfach
am tag anrufen werden soll ich dafür
jetzt auch wenn ich meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne bei einem live das schreibt geehrt
wurden die kommentare ob ich noch etwas
anderes einstellen soll et cetera pp wie
ich die ganze aktion findet und jetzt
wenn der postbote mit mir habt dann
checkt die infobox
[Musik]